a teenager hit and killed by a bus on
boulder highway in fact a surveillance
video here shedding some new light on
last night's deadly crash the boy has
been identified as 16 years old and it
doesn't appear that anyone slowed down
before actually the teenager didn't slow
down before darting into traffic sally
jaramillo spent the day in that area and
learned more about the victim
metro police say shortly after 10
o'clock last night surveillance video
shows oscar riding a stand-up electric
scooter on indios avenue they say he ran
a red light and was struck by a bus
christina eggman says it happened right
in front of where she works at the
boulder food mart she says she's in
shock and adds scooters shouldn't be on
busy streets they're not safe
they should be in a remote area maybe in
a skate park or a field or desert where
they got paths not on the sidewalks the
bus driver remained at the scene and did
not show any signs of impairment this is
the 125th traffic related fatality in
metro's jurisdiction